what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today
i will be discussing the latest twists
and turns
in the black clover story and man
this is a big deal the entire power
system in black clover may just have
been completely changed for the better
dante one of the strongest villains in
the entire story
is currently on the ropes at the hands
of a much weaker mage
and it's all thanks to the revolutionary
new information that we just learned
about the black clover magic power
system the world of black clover will
never be the same after this
so let's get into it if you enjoy the
black lover content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going just leave a like
and comment it only takes a second and
it's a totally free way to support
this channel and of course if you're new
to anime pro or maybe you watch our
videos but you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting
that option that says
all if you don't do that you're still
gonna miss a ton of our videos even if
you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works finally this
video will of course contain
black clover manga spoilers so please
proceed with caution
you have been warned now the last
chapter was absolutely
insane and at the end of that chapter
magna's incredible new magic spell
was revealed known as secret flame magic
soul chain death match this spell allows
magna to add his magic
and his opponent's magic together and
then divide their magic power
equally magna used this shocking new
ability on dante
and since dante is much much stronger
than magna
magna instantly became way stronger than
he was before
and dante became way weaker than he was
before to say that this new ability
shocked the entire black clover fandom
would be an understatement and in the
latest chapter we got
more information about how magna learned
to use
this insane new spell but
through this explanation we also learned
something very interesting about the
entire power system
in black clover something that is about
to change
everything we thought we knew about the
power scaling and
battle mechanics of black clover we
start things off with a flashback to six
months earlier when a desperate magna
literally
begged zora to teach him his own unique
way of fighting
magna simply does not have enough magic
power to fight
in the conventional mana intensive way
and since zora is also a commoner with
low amounts of magic
magna wants to learn from zora and get
stronger through
zora's guidance zoro's trap magic is a
very intricate form of magic that
enables even a commoner with low mana to
devise
incredibly tricky and powerful spells
for example
zora can create a counter trap spell
that absorbs an incoming spell
and then shoots it back at the original
user at two times the power
and speed magna wants to learn to use
this type of magic
in order to make up for his own lack of
raw magical power for one thing
magna doesn't want his friend luck to
surpass him
but even more importantly he doesn't
want to become a burden
on the black bulls if all the black
bulls manage to get stronger during the
6 months training period
and magna stays weak then he won't be
able to do his part
in the upcoming battle and he will just
be in everyone's way
in this moment magna reminds zora of his
own father
zara who was also a commoner and a fire
magic user who wasn't very powerful
in terms of raw magic amount but he made
up for it with his incredible
enthusiasm and effort so zora agrees to
help magna and to train together with
him
and he tells magna to get off his knees
and follow him
into his secret trap magic lair the two
mages then enter a room that looks like
edward elrick's
wet dream it is a chamber that is
absolutely covered with papers
containing complex magical formulas and
diagrams
clearly zora is not just a magic knight
in the conventional sense he is also a
magical
mad scientist or i guess i should say
magical mad
alchemist and he clearly spends
incredible amounts of time
and effort crafting his spells
zora also wants to become the strongest
possible version of himself
and to do that he cannot rely on large
amounts of magic
either from himself or from nature as a
low-born commoner he has to rely on
creating complex magical formulas ahead
of time
he has to work harder than everyone else
but
interestingly enough this approach
actually has its advantages
if you work hard ahead of time and spend
a lot of time perfecting it
you can create an extremely complicated
spell without the need to use a lot of
mana
and it seems that because less magical
power is required to create such spells
they will not disappear as quickly as
stronger spells
so these spells can actually be more
durable
under the right conditions at least
that's my understanding of what
zora was trying to say here but in order
for magna to learn to use these new
complex spells
he needs to study hard and dedicate
himself diligently to this type of
training
since magna tends to be a brash and
impatient guy
zora has his doubts about whether magna
will be able to pull
this off however magna is utterly
determined to make this happen
and he throws himself wholeheartedly
into studying
and training eventually after
considering many different variables
including the compatibility of various
magic attributes
magna comes up with an insane new magic
formula
zora himself has never even thought of
something like this before
but although the concept isn't
impossible
zora tells magna that he will need
extraordinary time
and patience in order to actually
execute
this spell so magna decides to spend the
next
six months studying and preparing to
execute
this one magic spell all of his focus
goes into preparing and executing this
one spell
perfectly and as we know he finally
succeeds
in his shocking battle against dante i
mentioned this in my previous video but
this reminds me so much of kurapika from
hunter hunter
training for so long to use just one
specific spell
under very specific conditions and then
seeing all of that hard work pay off
is just so rewarding we see that dante's
magic power level is represented by the
number
1000 and magnus is represented by the
number
two this means that dante is literally
500 times
stronger than magna and so under normal
circumstances there is
absolutely no chance that magna could be
daunting
but thanks to soul chain death match
dante's magic power goes down to 501
and magna's magic power shoots up to 501
meaning that the two fighters are now
evenly matched
but since magna knew that this would
happen and he has been preparing for it
for half a year
he has a clear advantage magna has the
element of surprise
and dante will need some time to adapt
to what
just happened not only did dante's own
power shrink in half
but his opponent's powers suddenly
skyrocketed
that is not an easy situation to deal
with out of nowhere
and in the middle of a battle magna then
explains to dante that the chain which
is now connecting the two of them
is their soul itself so if dante tries
to destroy the chain he will be
destroying his
own soul this means that dante is stuck
fighting magna
under these specific conditions and he
can't just break free from the chain by
severing it through force magna then
continues to attack
dante and dante fights back the whole
thing turns into a bit of a magical
boxing match
with the two mages exchanging punches
dante tries to use his gravity magic to
take
magna out but because the two mages have
the exact
same amount of magic power magna is able
to withstand the attack without
losing his composure magna then
counter-attacks
and just smashes through dante's body
with
punch after punch but of course we know
that dante possesses the power to
instantly repair his body so no matter
how much magna can damage his body
physically
dante just keeps regenerating
nevertheless
magna does not give up he continues to
smash
dante over and over again and he seems
to be using some sort of brass knuckles
to give his punches
even more power it doesn't matter if
dante is a devil user or the leader of
the enemies or even an immortal being
magna has decided to keep attacking
until he takes
this monster down and then the chapter
ends with magna smashing dante right in
the face
and seemingly taking him down at least
for the moment
wow this was another amazing crazy
chapter
and i still can't believe that tabata
managed to come up with a believable way
for someone as weak as magna to actually
go
toe-to-toe with dante and possibly even
win
i mean i don't think that magna will
really be the one to take dante down
my guess is that dante will win the
fight and then someone stronger like
asta or maybe even yami will end up
defeating him in the end
but i will say this on the off chance
that tabata really makes magna the one
to defeat
dante i would have so much respect for
that decision having a villain like
dante defeated by one of the strongest
heroes is the obvious and predictable
thing to do
but actually having a mage like magna
win a fight of this caliber
would be unexpected and extremely cool
again it's unlikely but the uniqueness
of something like that would definitely
make it extremely memorable and beyond
this one fight between dante and magna
these new revelations about how trap
magic works could change
everything in black clover this could
absolutely revolutionize the entire
power system
and allow even the weakest mages to find
a way to defeat
much stronger opponents as long as they
have enough time to prepare
a specific and complex spell like soul
chain
death match in my opinion this is an
epic addition to the black clover power
system
and it forces us to completely
re-evaluate what we thought we knew
about the magic in black clover any
random commoner with low mana could
theoretically become a highly effective
fighter with the right amount of
preparation
and training and with the right spell
they could take down much stronger
opponents
if this were to become common knowledge
in the world of black clover
it could totally turn the tables on the
entire dynamic between the commoners and
the nobles
i mean i could totally see the commoners
using their superior numbers
and these specific overpowered magic
spells to overthrow the entire noble
system i'm not saying that this is
really where the black clover story will
go
but this could theoretically happen and
that is what makes this new information
so revolutionary power creep is always a
big problem in every battle shown in
series
the longer a series goes on the stronger
the main characters will become through
various power-ups and transformations
but that usually means that the less
important characters will become too
weak to matter
in the grand scheme of things and so
they eventually become useless to the
plot
people often use shows like dragon ball
as an example
of this happening characters who were
once powerful like yamcha or krillin or
tien
become practically useless because of
how much stronger the main characters
like goku and vegeta have become
however with this new concept of weaker
mages using specific and complex spells
to take down
far stronger opponents tabata has
potentially solved the problem of power
creep in black clover
which is pretty amazing if handled
effectively
this could make so many interesting
characters relevant again
and i can't wait to see how tabata plans
to proceed
from here this is a very exciting moment
in the black clover story
let me know what you guys think did you
like the explanation of how magna
learned to use his new spell
and do you agree with me that this is a
revolutionary contribution to the black
clover power system
also do you think that magna could
really be the one to take
dante down or is he just enjoying a
brief moment in the sun before dante
defeats him and
zora finally are there any other cool
spells that you can think of that could
be similar to soul chain death match
and could be used by other commoners
definitely share your thoughts
down in the comments below if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more black clover content on the channel
please leave that like to let me know
and if you're new to anime opera or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram
at anime uproar a big thank you to all
of our anime outpour patrons for making
videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma red
haired raven
and av these guys are absolute mad lads
and disciples of lord twigo himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
pate heffa algertol dr cortman the
toasted chi
bang emperor otaku spidey life canal
tungsten targus
baked buddhist and you know finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsuki
cricket xp
rathune de ora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokami and water joy and
garcia ted no ted iceparky65 jessica
lafond metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
soul ray slice and dice and pillow if
you enjoy our videos
and you feel that they provide value for
you consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you